welcome to this video playing click or
zones are from from Spain and played an
English opening for a change I am at the
reversed draw pre yeah this is a gamer
this is them align the teammate of mine
plate ok now it's it's even okay I want
to prevent a bishop before I can't play
even the snow the d5 gambit line which
is telling on 55 from e3 it's not
possible anymore this is not just nice
for white really can just give up be
fine
hmm
jump it's possible maybe this is enough
compensation but okay I don't want to
take that away just play a positional
game could have taken see 685 I mean not
to not clear maybe this suppose this was
possibly good
yeah I have a hard time understanding
what he is doing
I thought d5 d6 now would be a good be
possible late as it is possible
questions is good now maybe just I just
add this yeah it just it just plays
instant moose that doesn't think much
about what's happening d6y d6 could be
very good could be could be a too
ambitious c6 97's the idea the idea is
not to play on the dark squares that are
seriously weakened the Queen deform
who's like this but of course this is
hanging and c7 is potentially lost but I
thought the dark squares would be some
compensation there's also night a4 b6
ideas this is this kind of this kind of
stuff it can happen that his suspicious
this is a problem now he just took it
yeah probably probably a good idea I
want to make sure that he cannot play d5
so let's start with this I'm not sure
that this was a great idea the sacrifice
is just a interesting uh-huh
yeah didn't see that coming
it's not a big issue maybe but i didn't
i didn't consider the move i'm wondering
what 24 now this may be it may be even
an option you can you can easily run out
of steam text XD 5c 5 and Bishop f4 it
is got 98 probably this is not enough
yeah this was too ambitious
yeah I'm two points down it is I have
some compensation but it's not enough
for two bonds
ya need to open it up only way to get
anything here what ok let's take here
first v6 is just hanging this is why I
wasn't getting the move
I did sir what's so weakening the
structure and i know i didn't i didn't
give understand anything Bishop to d3 or
what okay let's attack this first Roxy
six
I don't know what I want to play sure
everyone yeah maybe I should do that
cannot really get on the tech n I hope I
can still try to attack the pawn bishop
d for something rupee one or just wrote
bc one rock bc one is good hard to
prevent that actually look see one loop
c6 the Queen on b6 is also covering III
so a b6 was a strange decision I was
probably just playing a rather bad game
and b6 gave it gave it back to me I
think
check
taking see it I can take it black
resigned yeah I'd one that leads us away
I mean this was very weird play by black
and I was probably playing this to
ambitiously I was my original intention
was here d5 d6 but I thought why not
prepare this but here it is probably a
bad bad idea it's just too ambitious
ship Queenie five was the coolness of
course yeah 24 was was interesting this
is actually the the normal move I mean
the normal looking move but I was
thinking that I know what I'm talking
about is this I'm sorry in this position
Queen D for this is what i was thinking
about but he can play this sat at the
end played this and then get the pawn
and i can try that but here this gives
away the pawn and it's two points not
just one yeah pretty bad game by by both
players I guess here I'm just fishing
and b6 is just a big big blunder it's
also just a completely giving away the
structure yeah thanks for watching